malentendu chez le dentiste
la patiente a bien cru à un croche avec
le praticien un coeur avec les doigts
pas du tout lui ne faisait que son
travail
la séquence en rappelle une autre à
croire que ce quiproquo est courant dans
les cabinets dentaires
[Musique]
vous aussi
formidables
ici vivaient reclus un homme qui
souffrait du syndrome de diogène
depuis plusieurs années ce monsieur ont
cassé toutes ces ordures encore une
mission semer d'embûches
attend sur la marche
[Musique]
attention la marche
vous avez prévenu j'ai 14 50 euros 2h30
pour être tendance avec un trench vie la
belgique be les prix traquera chez sa
mère
1989 certaines stations balnéaires
interdisent de se promener en maillot de
bain dans la rue david pujadas jeune
journaliste d'investigation bravent
l'interdît
vous avez quelque chose sur le dos au
moins ça sera plus décent
si j'ai rien
bordeaux 12 c'est bien en plein mois
d'avril comme ça te rappeler que nos
différences font nos richesses plutôt
que nos combats et nos adversité et par
moment malheureusement la haine jesson
laïc de côté et vivons ensemble
les vingt-sept durcisse le ton envers
moscou en arrêtant leurs achats de
charbon russe soit 45 % des importations
de l'union européenne l'objectif éviter
leur dépendance énergétique envers la
russie moi j'assume totalement
totalement d'avoir constamment au nom de
la france parlé au président de la
russie pour éviter la paix pour éviter
la guerre pardonnez moi twitter va enfin
permettre à ses utilisateurs de modifier
leurs tweets cette fonctionnalité la
plus réclamée depuis des années sera
bientôt testé auprès des abonnés premium
qui paie 3 dollars par mois la phase de
test pourrait durer longtemps car il
faudra des garde-fous non pas pour ceux
de bonne foi qui veulent simplement
corriger une faute de frappe mais pour
d'autres qui pourraient modifier
totalement le sens d'un message après
publication c'est un écran qu'on est
capable de les ché
comment des boys à et donc il ya plein
de goût à l'intérieur
ça c'est ça permet quand vous commander
une pizza ou commander n'importe quoi
je sais pas après c'est au japon en ce
moment
hier soir c'était l'évènement que tous
les amoureux de politique et de
science-fiction attendait avec
impatience on parle bien sûr du retour
de l'hologramme de jean-luc mélenchon
le candidat d'union populaire qui était
en live dans 12 villes différentes et
toujours aussi zen pour l'occaz tous les
genres au
refus c'était tellement long que même
l'équipe les intermittents qui vont vous
posez les trucs sur scène se sont dit au
bout d'un moment c'est sympa janot mais
en terme d'heure j'ai rempli mon contrat
donc on remballe 1 et pour certains ça
devenait insupportable de ne plus jamais
être consulté
la direccte personnes tu vas me le
remettre à plaimont